é
entendre là-bas aujourd'hui. Ce
serait la bonne nouvelle.
Olivier Bourque.
- Depuis quelques semaines,
le téléphone sonne davantage et
les textos sont plus insistants
dans ce nenenet de courtage
hypothécaire.
- C'est exactement là que
ça fait mal actuellement,
c'est sur l'augmentation
du paiement hypothécaire
sur le budget.
AvAvAvec 7 hausses d'affilée du
taux directeur, Philippe Simard
doit bien souvent rassurer
les clients qui ont vu
leur budget se resserrer.
PHILIPPE SIMARD, directeur
hyporererere Québec, Ratehub.ca
- On pouvait s'attendre
un petit peu à des hausse
du taux directeur, mais
de cet ordre-là, ça a surpris
vraiment tout le monde.
- Ce matin, la Banquananananada
a haussé d'un demi-point de
pourcentage son taux directeur,
qui est maintenant à 4,25 %.
Dans un des cycles aussi
les plus importants de
son histoire, l'impact est
direct; il en coûtera donc
plus pour les emprunteurs.
nonononons, par exemple,
une hypothèque de 300 000 $.
Au début de l'année, avec
un taux variable de vos 2 %,vove
à payer 1270 $ mensuellement.
Mais avec un taux à 5 %,
il en coûtera plus de 1700 $,
une hausse de 500 $.
- Ce sont ces gens-là qui
commencent à recevoir des appels
de leur banque, parce que...
ils atteignent un point
où à certains moments,
il y a des gens qui ne payent
plus du tout de capi
leur prêt hypothécaire, et là,
évidemment, il y a des actions
qui doivent être portées
sur leur hypothèque.
- Avec inflation qui était de
6,9 % en octobre, cette banque
alimentaire a remarqué
une hausse de la demande.
FOUAD ZERHOUNI, Mouvement
fraternité multiethnique- - - -u
le thermomètre non officiel
de la situation économique
parce que nous sommes
la première porte d'entrée
pour les gens qui
en situation de précarité.
- Les Montréalais rencontrés
espèrent, quant à eux,
avoir un répit.
- Moi, je trouve que c'est
en train d'étouffer les gens.
Ça monte de partout,
de tous bords, tous côtés.
- On en a parlé mal. Jusque-là.
De tout. Même en tant que
travailleur, on n'arrive pas.
- À quand le retour de
la baisse des taux d'intérêt?
La Banque du Canada constate
que l'inflation est encore
trop élevée, mais ouvre
la porte à la fin d'un cycle.
Le contexte économique risque
de se corser encore davantage
en 2023, avelelelelelelele
récession qui risque d'avoir
encore plus d'impacts sur
le portefeuille des ménages.
Ici Olivier Bourque,
Radio M M M M M M Montréa